joining me now is Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief of the Federalist in
Miranda Devine New York Post columnist
they are both Fox News contributors
Molly just as shocking as these
Revelations were from Archer the
statement from the White House claiming
that this proves President Biden did
nothing wrong yeah that was a very
interesting statement to get from the
White House it of course matches what
their interest is but what happened
today was actually quite breathtaking we
have Devin Archer saying that barisma
Executives asked Hunter Biden to help
them get the prosecutor who's going
after them fired we know everyone knows
nobody denies that Joe Biden was the
Ukraine Point person in the Obama
Administration we know that five days
later Joe Biden was speaking in front of
the Ukrainian Parliament laying the
groundwork to get this guy fired and
then as you showed he bragged about
getting it done within just a few short
months this teaches us so much about how
that Biden family business worked
foreign oligarchs and Ukraine is just
one example it's also Romania and China
and Russia paid millions of dollars to
the Biden family for just this type of
action and this is you know this is
amazingly corrupt Behavior whether the
Biden White House wants to admit it or
not now Miranda we played that little
snippet from Congressman Goldman
um the Democrat who was in the hearing
today he came out and they clearly just
decided he had the cred from impeachment
right so they were going to use him as
the Susan Rice during Benghazi I know
you guys love that that comparison but
this is what he claimed was Vindicated
today watch this there is not a shred of
evidence of a single conflict of
interest of President Biden ever doing
anything in connection or in relation to
Hunter Biden's business ventures other
than advocating for the removal of a
prosecutor General
who was advantageous to barisma
Miranda I mean he's kind of flop
sweating there if you look closely and I
think for good reason your reaction
well that in itself Dan Goldman's done
it again he seems to he's he's playing
the role of the defense Council for the
Biden family but he can't seem to get
out of his prosecutorial previous role
because he's making the case for the
prosecution against Joe Biden here again
so uh Victor shoken at the very time
that he was removed on the orders of Joe
Biden the prosecutor there he was
investigating barisma the country that
the company that was paying Hunter Biden
83 000 a month so he uh within a few
months of uh of um Hunter Biden and and
Devin Archer getting Joe Biden on the
phone to talk to their barisma pay
masters in Dubai we had Victor shoken
seizing all property belonging to the
owner of barisma
um in Kiev and so he was operating as a
thorn in the side of barisma and we know
that because the barisma executives were
extorting and trying to get Devin Archer
and and Hunter Biden to make to do
something about shoken because it was
causing them problems so again this
yeah yeah I'm just saying you took the
words out of my mouth I mean the fact
pattern here Molly is not this is not a
coincidence this all just happened to
happen at the same time what talent that
you may be aware of and all you're
reporting does Hunter Biden have an
international finance well this is
what's so amazing you know we had all
the drama during the Trump
Administration which whatever you want
to say about this family they were known
as a global business involving real
estate and our media were so curious
about every little aspect of that here
you have the Biden family business
there's not a single like tangible thing
that they offer other than changes to
U.S policy which we now have evidence
that there was a change in U.S policy
that was advantageous to uh barisma
which was paying the vice president's
son money for that access these types of
things or we also learned you know there
was a Moscow wife of the former mayor of
Moscow was giving money to the bidens
she's kind of mysteriously not on the
sanction list that we have against also
so many Russians so this is what was
offered but there's nothing tangible
um or or like that anyone would
realistically pay Hunter Biden or other
Biden family members for other than that
access to Joe Biden and Miranda more of
the spin coming out of this was that
well Hunter was selling the illusion
that word was thrown out today the
illusion that his father would step in
and help so we're supposed to believe I
guess that he cheated his clients and
that all these huge conglomerates and
sophisticated International financiers
that they're just writing checks for
nothing I mean and if so did Hunter
Biden declare a gift on his on his tax
return because that would be subject to
gift tax if in fact he was paid to do
nothing I don't believe he did
look the spin coming out of the
Democrats is just desperate and
hilarious uh to pretend that it's
nothing that Joe Biden appeared on
speakerphone at as many as 20 business
meetings that Hunter was having with his
overseas benefactors who were spraying
him with diamonds and cash to pretend
that that's nothing and that Joe Biden
was just dialed in to talk about the
weather of course Joe Biden is not going
to discuss the fine points of the deal
chairman he's it's just the whole point
of influence peddling is to demonstrate
that you can get the most powerful man
in that country in Ukraine or China uh
on the phone at a moment's notice and
that's what was demonstrated with those
phone calls and those dinners and
everybody knows that and you know I I
think the Democrats think they can get
away with it because the New York Times
and CNN and Washington Post will not
report on this as they should they will
report it as the spin from the White
House which is that Joe Biden's just a
father that he he calls his father he
calls his son every day yes
but then yeah but but there was no
conflict Molly because Joe Biden didn't
say well by the way barisma my son who
is actually working and to help erisma
and they might be helped if this guy
gets fired he needed to say that nothing
but conflict of interest when you're
taking money from foreign oligarchs for
access to your father who's vice
president Molly and Miranda great to see
you tonight both thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else